hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the losers wrecked of the
chessable Master Series Magnus Carlsen
vs Lavon aronian and they are playing
for a chance to play against Hikaru
Nakamura in the finals of the losers
bracket of the adjustable Masters now
that's uh uh a weird thing to say but
that's how they uh they do things there
and the winner of the uh of the finals
of the losers bracket will face Fabiano
Corona in the grand final of the winners
bracket so there we have it let's check
it out this is the first rapid game of
the Magnus versus Levon match uh it's a
very cool game they play uh some uh very
old old school chess uh lines that are
used in this game are over 100 years old
uh they did back over like to the to the
times of alihin and capablanca so you
guys will enjoy this game at the
positions that happen are are very
enjoyable so Magnus with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to C4 he goes for
the English opening with Knight to F6 by
11 Knight to C 3e5 Knight to F3 and now
Knight to C6 the Four Knights of the
English opening with D4 and now pretty
much everyone plays ecapt or Sandy for
it so it's uh pretty mandatory as it's
the only move that uh says uh is okay
for black the all the other moves that
the engine says is are either equal or
or just straight up better for black but
here we have E4 by 11 and this is the uh
so-called Bradley Beach variation now
it's a funky name I've never heard I've
heard about it so uh of course of course
I went to check why it's called the
Bradley Beach variation and they had two
very strong tournaments at Bradley Beach
one in
1929 one in 1928 one in 1929 uh the one
that I've checked where the variation
got its name from is the year Alexander
alejin visited
that tournament and he won the
tournament with eight and a half out of
nine something like that and the first
game I checked where ayaking had the
black pieces he faced a gentleman named
uh Horus Ransom Bigelow alejin went for
this E4 uh ee for Pawn push and he won a
great game with it in that game course
Bigelow went for Knight D5 which is
considered a sub-optimal move only the
second top move recommended by the
engine but of course here Magnus knows
better he plays Knight back to D2 which
is of course the first top move
recommended by the engine and the game
continues and also I did not know this
uh the uh the return match between
Alexander Legend and Jose Raul
capablanca was supposed to be played in
uh in Bradley Beach so I I did not know
that I knew of course that they were
there were negotiations for the rematch
to happen uh but it never happened if it
did happen it would be played here in uh
uh in in Bradley Beach so uh I I know
that maybe some of you guys didn't know
that either so okay Knight the D2 Magnus
goes for the Top Line against this with
Bishop to B4 and now Pawn to E3 with
Bishop captures B captures and now 11
just castles and here we reached a
position from the thumbnail it's a very
uh you know standard Pawn structure with
uh sort of a sort of resembling uh
something that could come from from a
name so Indian uh but there's there's
this E4 Pawn kind of blockading uh White
setup but okay here Magnus goes for Pawn
to G4 and he wants to play G5 attack the
knight uh and attack the black king and
of course it is now as of movie that we
have a completely new game uh because G4
has never been attempted here we have D6
and now Pawn to G5 Lavon goes for Knight
to D7 and Knight captures an E4 Magnus
wins the pawn uh but lemon says okay
it's not a problem my king is um already
Castle to safety I'm just gonna play F5
your king is stuck on E1 now I'm just
gonna attack it and I should have a
great game here and Okay g captures an
F6 Alpha Knight captures and Knight back
to G3 by Magnus so can magnus's King
survive here on E1 we have Queen to E8
by Lavon and now the queen is nicely
positioned on the E file but also you
can just shift the queen to G6 to F7 or
wherever you need Pawn to F3 not
allowing the knight any funky squares
and also preparing E4 in some lines we
have B6 now preparing Bishop to B7 and
as Magnus of course doesn't like this he
immediately puts the Rook on G1 there's
a semi-openg file so The Rook definitely
belongs there Knights the A5 putting
pressure on the on the C4 pawn and now
Pawn to E4 Magnus grabs the full Center
not worried about his King being on E1
we have King to h8 by Levon he's ready
to open up the possession but before
that he wants to get the King off of the
G file end off of this diagonal at some
point it might become relevant so King
th8 and now Bishop to D3 Magnus playing
uh pretty much in the same way as if his
King was already castled but it's not
it's still an E1 so okay Knight to H5 11
now offers the trade Knight and queen to
E2 nicely putting the the queen and the
E file with 9 the F4 now forcing Magnus
to give up his Bishop pair as the he's
either going to pick up the light score
bishop or Magnus has to give up the dark
Square Bishop so Bishop captures we have
Rook captures on F4 and now Queen to E3
attacking The Rook on F4 we have Rook
back the f8 and now Pawn to C5 a very
tricky move by Magnus and also just
showing you how uh he doesn't care about
his King being a new one he just wants
to open up the position uh because it's
positionally good for him to to do so so
here B captures on C5 we have D captures
and C5 voluntarily breaking up his
strong Center Quinta E5 now putting
pressure on this Pawn here and now comes
Knight the E2 the Queen the queen to E5
also attacks the C3 Pawn so Magnus just
defends it and now Queen captures on C5
and look at this queen captures on C5 D
can't presents C5 and all of a sudden
we've reached an end game with equal
material it's just that levon's uh C
Pawn is doubled so Magnus definitely has
the upper hand here we have King F2
Magnus wants to bring his King closer to
the action Bishop to E6 and now just to
Rook the G5 how can Levon defend the C5
Pawn well he he could play at Knight B7
it's a weird move and the Knight
probably won't be able to stay there
forever but you know you could try this
Eleven on the other hand goes for the
active plan Rotator d8 puts pressure on
the bishop and now while you would
expect King D3 from Magnus Magnus in
fact goes Bishop to B5 and this allows
Levon a very tricky move that would not
be possible if you just kept the bishop
here and play King D3 but uh you know
you give Levon one chance to wiggle out
he's gonna do it and here he plays Pawn
to A6 he gives up this Pawn in order to
to save this pawn and get a lot of
activities look at this bishop captures
on A6 Rook to A8 the bishop goes back to
D3 and now you could actually play C4
because the Knight is now nicely covered
by The Rook but no Levon goes Knight to
B3 attacks the rook and of course
captures is impossible because of Rook
captures work so here Rook to D1 and now
Rook captures an A2 we have King to E3
uh as the Knight cannot move so you
don't want to run into any tactics King
to E3 and now just Pawn to H6 we have
Rook the E5 and now Bishop to F7 and
again uh material balance has been
restored and the Levon likes his
position he has a very active position
but uh objectively magnus's position is
much much better here the pawns are
still weak and the magnus's pieces are
very active or they soon will be so
Bishop to F7 is a really a funny looking
move Magnus tries to take advantage of
it the Rook Rook Dev 7 now you have to
be worried about something like Bishop
to C4 here so Knight the A5 stopping
that and now Rook captures and c5s Magna
starts collecting here we have Pawn to
C6 and now Pawn to H4 now the Knight can
move you don't have to worry about that
pawn on H2 Rook the A3 and now we have
Knight the D4 and here Levon really out
of options here not a lot of active
moves he goes for Knight to C4 check and
he gives up two pieces for the rook and
that's how he will he will try to hold
this and okay Magnus accepts Rook
captures on C4 Bishop captures on C4
Bishop captures and now Rook captures on
C3 with check Magnus blocks this would
Bishop to D3 and now it's three pawns
each however Magnus does have a bishop
and Knight against the rook and the with
perfect play of course you should win
this so let's see how he does it Rook to
d8 uh Knight the E2 now attacking The
Rook end of the bishop on D3 is
sufficiently defended so Rook day three
Levon is now dreaming of some C5 C4
action uh Knight to F4 by Magnus we have
Pawn to C5 and now of course C4 will be
winning for black but to Rook the C1
Magnus stops it with Pawn to G5 captures
captures and now just Knights to D5 Now
The Rook is cut off from attacking the
bishop on D3 and Magnus can start moving
his pieces around a little bit with
rooked the C8 and now Knight the C3 uh
we have King to G7 Levon starts bringing
his King into the game knight uh B1
attacks The Rook on A3 Rook the A2 and
now Knights the D2 and now you have full
control over the C4 square and you have
no longer uh no you no longer have to
worry about uh eleven actually pushing
C4 so King to F6 Knight to C4 we all
know the best way to block it the past
Pawn is by putting a nice uh on a square
in front of it uh Rook to B8 now and now
Rook the H1 trying to get some uh action
behind the the black king king to G7 and
now of course Ponte E5 opening up this
daggle now Rook to H7 is coming solavon
stops this offers a rook trade and while
Magnus could do it he keeps the tension
Rook to G1 puts pressure on the pawn
here Rook the H5 and not a very active
Square for the black Rook but uh you
know Levon is very low on time he
doesn't have all that much time to
choose Knight to D6 and now Rook to A3
not allowing the bishop to move so of
course King to E4 and now Rook the H4
with check Magnus blocks it would Rook
to G4 and now King the f8 uh you could
also consider a move like a rook
captures and then F captures on G4 uh
which would of course still be
completely winning for white but you
know every every other option is also
winning for white so you don't really
gain all that much King the Fate was
played with Bishop to C4 and now Rook
captures on G4 with f characters and now
Rook to G3 going after the G3 Pawn but
now King to F5 and now you can see that
the the squares around the black king
will become thinner thinner and thinner
thinner uh this cover this cover this
cover this cover that this will uh soon
be covered once the the black king gets
here and then it's merely a matter of
pushing the pass Pawn to Victory so Rook
the E3 Levon has one more plan or you
know uh one small vial of poison to try
and use against Magnus King to F6 and
now Rook F3 check Knight the F5 and now
Rook the F4 attacking the G4 pawn and
the bishop on C4 and it seems that the
pawn will fall and Levon will get his
counter play however here Magnus just
played Ponte E6 and he was in this
position animal 59 that Levon arunan
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here that's one way to
do it even a trickier way to do it is
Bishop to F7 now this is just
Unstoppable Checkmate you will have to
give up the rook in order to stop this
like real captors and G4 E6 Rook D4 E7
and now you have to capture captures
captures and of course you are
completely winning its mate on the next
move regardless of what the black plays
but Magnus played Pawn to E6 and it's
pretty much the same thing point is that
once the bishop is captured you have E7
with check and once the king hits E8 now
you deliver a check you can go Knight
G's seven check you can go Knight to D6
check doesn't matter black king will
have to move and you will queen that
pawn with check and then win the uh win
The Rook uh pretty much uh on the next
move or maybe in a couple of moves but
now of course it's completely winning
for white so yeah very nicely done by
Magnus and I've just uh learned uh
looking at my other screen that the
second game between Magnus and Levon has
finished which means that uh and of
course the Magnus won the second game as
well which means that now we will have
Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura in
the finals of the losers bracket of the
chessball Masters and the winner will
face Fabiana corvana in the grand and
final of the chessable Masters division
one uh I know what do you want to do so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Magnus
Lavon uh not his day but you know you're
if you're playing against Magnus you
can't always have your day I would like
to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube Eric
Colton even Sterling uh philcastle
attacks Guru and Joshua Hadley for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day